we don't really like calling in our mo
because it has a lot of connotations to
it this is it's there's no levels
there's no sort of like learning of
skills and grinding and stuff like that
you basically in a huge open world of
thousands of islands and you're
basically dumped in this world you don't
really have a bearing on where you are
it's all about understanding the world
and sort of finding a place there so you
you kind of like draw the maps or you
and a group of other players who are
essentially sort of building ships to
fly between these islands and some of
you'll discover ruins and soar temples
and stuff like that and we haven't got
the wildlife in there yet but we're kind
of currently building that through kind
of going around discovering and finding
sort of secrets and stuff about you
actually be able to build stronger
airships and kind of fly further into
different really the world it's
essentially this freedom of movement you
just inspire kind of like Skies of
Arcadia and wind waker in the distance
you just see I can island out there and
knowing that you can go there and it's
your choice you can just and you never
know what you might run into it could be
other players it could be particularly
dangerous wildlife because the server
we're having the server technology we're
using essentially has infinite space to
expand so the world could end up being
just thousands of kilometres with tens
of thousands of islands you might not
even see them all every island there
could be there could be players that
could be old the ecosystems gone run
amok so there could be so much more
powerful creatures there than you would
want the even stuff like we have
obviously there's Network physics so
you kind of share in the happiness like
that and we because it's a cracking game
you do collect resources now the actual
mechanics of like kind a little bit like
users clicking right now there will be a
little bit more involved but it's it's
taking this kind of if we are going to
harvest sort of trees for wood how can
you make it just more interesting the
idea that it's still slightly dangerous
and could fall on you and yeah you just
it's a little bit more involved and then
those trees have we gone on any one sort
of coming up to sign they all see the
results of this repin is persistent in
the world anyone arriving here in a few
months time or weeks time will just
simply see the trees as they are and the
technology lets everything persist the
big thing for us which is again you know
don't use word MMO but everyone always
wanted a way that their actions affect
the world and it's never really been
possible not without a little bit forced
so let's sort of things so in this world
everything you do lose marks instantly
burn out to cutting down trees you're
kind of telling a story of like when you
arrived and started to carve up the this
particular island then so everything you
kind of do like has a mark if you should
crash a ship if you lose an engine it
lands on an island it'll stay there if
someone can come by and take it for
themselves and just attach it to their
own ship here we have like a little
camps that up and that's kind of I'll
see the the art Scott really final with
these things we still gotta redo some of
the designs of things but so that that
you know we I think we saw placed easier
in a week but they're still there now
and I think it's all parts we've like
left this will remain I do have the
grappling hook which is on the right
Mouse so but do I just click it will
just attach where my cursor is pointing
but if I hold it down it will lock the
camera and I can attach anyway so I can
attach up to that tree up there or that
branch
they're now at the moment it does
instantly appear but we have a hope
they're sort of firing sort of animation
for it what it allows you to do is
essentially be spider-man and it just
choose where you want to actually attach
so I can just say get rid of there and
swing off to that attach that tree there
and you can rope in and create slack and
let go and then potentially what not hit
anything
bored elicited because we're all like
physics based and if I just like spin
there I can kind of like spin myself
then open my sort of paraglider there
you are using sort of like momentum and
physics and stuff like that so we find
most people just kind of collide into a
rock and knock themselves out like that
and the ropes all physical as well so if
I attach to this sort of tree and I walk
over here it'll like I can create a
little web wrapping around the trees
just for no other reason than why not
I'll see if I'm like kind of swinging a
speed that wall if I wrap around
something it orbs you cause momentum I
can sort of slingshot myself
you can like lose resources if you're
not careful because it's physics so it's
like oh well there we go there we've
just lost an entire tree so go as what
you'll be doing essentially in the game
is finding sort of you start the game
stranded on an island and you can sort
of build like a rudimentary dinghy of
some kind like a basic ship and then
you're able to basically pick a
destination you can see Ireland sort of
like dotting the skyline then you just
head towards them when you find [ __ ]
here we've got some ruins we haven't got
the systems in place we were able to
every island he'll have like a finite
amount of resources for you to scan and
that gives you kind of knowledge which
in turn
allows you to kind of generate the
schematics which could be new equipment
like the hang glider it could be new
weapons new engines stuff like that
so you see here I took a picture of me
taking a selfie of the island I put that
picture on my ship so it's like this
weird picture of a picture uh-huh but
this is like the kind of player
storytelling we want to push because
it's persistent you might we might crash
this ship later on or something like
that and as a player you can arrive on
an island and actually find a picture
frame that's almost taken a picture
they've taken it's not a thing we've
planted this developers that's someone
just has that they have the tools to
take a picture they have the tools to
make a camera if they've crashed a ship
in some way you can go through the
wreckage of a ship and actually sort of
almost discover the story of their
adventure I guess okay so see there will
be there different biomes in the game so
but right now they just kind of mix in
together later on there'll be the huge
storms that divided the world into
regions so if you want to hit the desert
lands you're gonna have to bust through
a huge sandstorm your ship askme path
laughs to basically fly through that I'm
zooming move my anger and my candid
camera I can kind of like just so catch
glimpses of other players just no
exploring around I can maybe snap a
picture of them and then leave the camp
the picture somewhere where they might
be walking by and just sort of be
creeped out but like someone has been
watching them as they go it would go
about exploring so right now I'm just
cheating in like all of our materials
but and none of the actual material
balancing is at all
so let me talk about sort of being
careful with with crafting and and how
we play with physics is if I'm gonna
build an engine once it's actually
crafted it enters the world just like a
physical object the building is all
completely cooperative
so wherever Enriquez if he comes over
here
kiss me a hand so now I'm like I've just
basically lost that engine because it's
now just off if I try and reel it it's
just much much heavier than me it's
gonna pull me along
yeah and if basically this when a ship
is docked to the shipyard here it has
like a sphere of influence this will
actually pick up objects and basically
strap it onto the ship now if an engine
for example has just actually like gone
down a hill and off the island I think
it might have done I think it found a
hole yeah that's gone we pretend that
like this was this was blown off by
someone like hit by a cannon and sort of
like just left behind I'll try not to
let it go fall down in Ireland's thing I
just built some cause and just make it
flyable I'm gonna try to stop this thing
whoop okay let's slow you down
it should be fine okay so like getting
it back up this all right JJ agency
that's cool so like getting this up to
here would be a pain in the ass because
it's a lot heavier than we are we could
maybe manage it with more people but the
technology the lesser ships why right
now it's being suspended by the shipyard
in order for that thing to float
actually have to build a core you know
you attach these cores to a ship nose
things you definitely want to stay alive
but we can kind of play with the physics
of the world this is kind of how we
develop all our features we sort of
approach it in like how can this be used
in the most interesting ways so while
this thing is currently pretty heavy and
kind of just about roll it but it's
gonna be a bit annoying
I can build these little not pictures I
mean take a picture of it I can build
these little mini calls and I can attach
it to this the same thing the same
technology that basically lets ships
float so I just attach many ones and
then this engine is now weightless so
now I can actually move it so if I was
to have found this on an island
somewhere and you know I deem it sort of
better than any of the engines I can
build I can be like sweet I'm taking
this from
so so if it actually sings on I can use
my grappling hook just to pull it back
sort of into our little camp that we're
building I there's one old Christ that's
cool right so now that's yeah so but
those things can be attached to any
object in the game song little cutting
down those trees earlier I can attach
his little mini corselet and actually
weight that weightless and you can use
that like either foot sort of bringing
it back to camp or you can use it as a
weapon you can drop it on the top of
something like that because the ship
course can only hold a certain amount of
weight so you're kind of you're
balancing the sort of how much your ship
can carry so now right here and wreak
foolishly put all our cores the most
important part of the ship because what
keeps it afloat
put it on top deck you probably want
that now most ships will have multiple
decks this one doesn't but you can still
straps off to the bottom so I've now
kind of put that basically in the
innards of the ship and what I can do
then is if I sort of start building some
metal panels but can then basically
strap that to the ship and you'll see it
will then Bend around the hull and
that's basically how you create armor
plating that means that any kind of
attack is when you've eventually kind of
plated up your whole ship they're going
to need to they're going to need to
blast through the plating you busy you
you have a sank apprenticeship needs
like a fuel tank off the engine the
cause killer flow Y built there was a
response system my name on it
and when i dial we spawn now it's not
we're not really punish death so much
you will lose what's kind of like in
your inventory but you could go back to
your body darks I'll star and find all
that stuff again unless of course you
fell off an island in which case well
then it's gone so yeah you're free to
sleep in still applies when it ships
moving got and enric's or tailing off
there now we've got none of the Helms
that could be dangerous you can move
around you can also sort of jump off the
ship jump onto a ship so there's
complete freedom moving we can we can
burn past another ship and actually jump
off and just attach to it there's no
weird sort of like systems that let like
ships dock together or you know I can
one of the things it's like the
Assassin's Creed Black Flag like
boarding thing you have to like hold
beat aboard and all this stuff this
doesn't apply
game you can just sort of grab jump onto
anything that's moving and grapple onto
it there
Oh same things it's two ships flying we
can turn under savvy now you can have
explosives and stuff like that but here
you do have a little tool look it's the
same thing you would use to harvest
materials are also harvests ship parts
and stuff so you get some little stir
way who's then just sort of like
breaking off your engines and now all
tumble and again physics will take over
and I'll just tumble off the island and
that's now gone but you could have like
either you could do that just to stop
the guy promoting and now the ship is
actually if I'd hit forward now the ship
will just turn automatically because
it's only got one engine so it's not
really out of fly properly so kind of
you can get screwed over in that regard
you have to keep your speed down but
these little tools I can use earlier so
then if I was like I want to steal this
guy's engine it's amazing you could
sneak aboard
yeah you've broken off and it'll fall
and so you could you know you could lose
it but using a combination of these
little cause I was using earlier I can
actually start to so now already pre
attach them are you gonna crashes and so
now I can be like right I've already set
it up for like stealing so if he's not
aware of me because he's too busy flying
like now I would detach the engine but
it's not gonna fall nope so it's got the
full things attached to it so I can then
grab and I'm getting away with it now
and I can have like maybe another ship
below and slowly sort of parachute my
way down he's using this engine I've
just stolen from their ship take it with
me and and find my own ship and just
attach it on to
see so he's definitely screwed now yes
the cause will allow him sort of to
raise and lower the ship and if we s if
we could try Wikus drag the ship back to
like a shipyard yeah if I am build a new
one I say build I'll cheat myself a new
one in the interest of time so yeah this
ship can't move but there should be
enough of us everything in the world is
a physical object so if we use our
combined might of pulling with ropes we
should be able to pull the ship over
sort of shipyard so it's always like
Salvage of all the ships are the one
thing that when you lose them they're
gone so they need to be kind of robust
so in this case we can still we can
still save it we're just gonna boom so
now we can that engine I ripped off
earlier I just take off that core so
they're like no don't roll away oh I
know it's damaged it's made to repair it
again all the effects work is like super
placeholder II hence where you have the
weird green glows and all that kind of
stuff we're just sort of getting the
technology to play ball so we're just
repairing this thing I don't know sweet
then I can just pick it up and because
of the ships no doctory shipyard I can
just bolt the engine back on and today
we can now kind of fly I we already had
to throttle up so we should probably
turn that off look there we go yes so um
those are kind of how we sort of play
with all of the physics and their
systems and so eventually when you are
flying through the storms and stuff it
is a it's not necessarily clear barrier
it's is your ship heavy enough is it
powerful enough to basically power
through these sort of storms to new
areas so this is a much much bigger ship
as you can see it's got sort of multiple
decks
and lots and lots of space for stuff and
actually it's just way less rubbish by
comparison and this is where the kind of
the important stuff comes in so you know
it's all the important stuff we kind of
put below deck we can look out the
window and see sort of this person
trying to fly his ship and failing at it
and so here we have the like respawns
and I can put my name there and you can
see the members of the crew if this
thing goes down and you know again we
for some reason we've built some cows on
the inside here and plated them up but
there is there could be like a gameplay
reason for that because you can be like
you know someone sees a ship coming as
how it's not heavily armed but then you
can try to start to fire at the inside
of my ship
I'm just damaging the plate that I can
be like haha surprise hidden hidden
hidden cannon and then start firing at
someone Oh out of a like a now a
newly-formed hole in my ship Isis but
he's constructing over that's fine yeah
then you have audio storage crates and
there's more cannons down here and you
can place these forever if you want so
you can kind of create your own sort of
battle cruiser I suppose and you can put
in now the ship whole shaping stuff that
we're developing at the moment will
actually get you sort to find the shape
of all of this and where the kind of
stairs are and all this magical stuff we
have all the ship instruments up here so
we're flying the helm earlier we didn't
actually put on any sort of instruments
so the pilot kind of almost builds their
own UI so we've got the artificial
horizon we've got now achieved Mia there
if I sort of raise a ship up you'll see
that also kind of counting up you then
got the fuel we then got a heading so
we're like facing north then we've got
speed if I crank this ship up there stop
see all the engines will come on
the speed sort of start cranking up this
thing's massive and not soul so you
ain't going to be very useful
secretive if you're flying around with
this thing but again you can grab around
you can see like this slingshot effect
when moats or rope sort of wraps around
it
so you can see how boarding a ship like
this is a part like they're not going to
know you're there because you could be
you know could be burning through the
sky and you're just sort of casually
with dangling off you could and on the
wing and start sort of salvaging the
metal plating
you